what's the grossest thing that an actor
had to do to nail a performance well one
female actress had to actually put a
live bird in her mouth keep watching to
find out who it was
there has long been talk of halle berry
going to extraordinary links to get into
character as vivian alongside samuel
jackson in jungle fever spike lee's 1991
exploration of romance and race
relations jackson portrayed the
scene-stealing drug-out brother of
wesley snipes lead character named gator
while barry was gator's hard scrabble
main squeeze jungle fever features a
memorable scene that called for jackson
and barry to bicker back and forth when
gator wants some alone time with his
brother for barry who came from the
world of modeling it was an unexpected
role and one she had worked hard to land
to prepare for the part she spent
several weeks not bathing with most
reports claiming that she went unwashed
for two weeks some even speculated that
her avoidance of soap and water went as
long as two months in 2012 the oscar
winner told talk show host wendy
williams that the method tale was no
exaggeration claiming to have avoided
bathing for about 10 days she said it's
true ask sam jackson he had to get with
it constantly barry elaborated in a 2016
interview saying spike lee wanted me to
read for a different role and i read
that part fine enough but then i said to
spike you know i really am eyeing this
crackhole role it was an amazing way to
start my career
yes the rumors are true nicholas cage
ate cockroaches cast in the role of
peter love a literary agent suffering
from paranoid delusions the 1988 horror
comedy vampire's kiss cage was a fast
rising hollywood star at the time he was
known for taking daring risks and making
let's call them unique choices in his
mannerisms in the years since the box
office flop has become a cult hit as
well as a dependable halloween watch
kiss also offers viewers the chance to
watch the actor do some off-the-wall
things from falling down stairs to
tearing a room apart to screaming the
alphabet in its entirety jumping on
desks chasing pigeons and pouring hot
yogurt on his toes the odd performance
has since fed multiple memes and is
considered a landmark in the cinematic
evolution of cage perhaps the most
interesting actor of his generation to
convincingly portray love's spiraling
descent into insanity cage made a habit
of offering to do more than what was
being asked of him for one scene in
particular though the script only called
for loaves to slurp down a raw egg cage
felt more was needed speaking to the
ringer in 2019 about the infamous movie
moment biermann recalled that day on set
he shared nicholas cage said to me the
thing i hate most in the world are
cockroaches so let me eat a cockroach i
thought this is terrific i sent my prop
people down into the boiler room they
brought me a box divided up into little
sections with tissue paper the
cockroaches were there lined up for me
to cast he added i think they're
actually called water bugs they're
bigger than cockroaches i couldn't think
of a more horrible job if i wanted to
major spoilers for the 2014 murder
mystery thriller gone girl if you've
seen the film you'll know the gruesome
final act that rosamund pike must
perform as amy dunn jilted lover and
missing person after attempting to
escape her apparently abusive and
unfaithful husband nick played by ben
affleck amy hides out with another
formerly abusive ex-boyfriend desi she
makes the world believe she has
disappeared while knowingly implicating
nick in the process the film follows
nick's attempts to clear his name and
find his wife with amy being revealed as
a ruthless cunning woman out to destroy
her husband's life in the film's climax
amy decides to return to nick and is
forced to murder desi and frame him for
her disappearance so she and her husband
can live happily ever after actress
roseman pike was required to believably
slice the throat of actor neil patrick
harris who played desi it was a key
scene that she wanted to be prepared for
so she did what any reasonable person
would she got a hold of some pig
carcasses and pretended to murder them
the actress told glider in 2016 if
you're going to do something like that
you have to do it with a certain degree
of accuracy i had no idea how much force
you needed to slice someone's throat i
actually went to a butcher and asked
them if they wouldn't mind me just using
a box cutter on a pig carcass just to
understand what it would be like
matt damon was nothing if not dedicated
when he took on the role of max decosta
a blue-collar worker in a dystopian
future version of los angeles in the
2013 film elysium the movie was a much
anticipated follow-up to director neil
blomkamp's indie hit district 9 a
science fiction drama featuring overt
commentary on south african apartheid
with elysium blomkamp took the formula
that worked so well before this included
its social commentary and dialed it up a
notch adding a bigger budget bigger sets
and bigger stars like damon and jodie
foster but that expanded fx budget
didn't mean the entire movie would be
filmed on green screen so to portray los
angeles in a future where pollution
overpopulation and climate change had
ravaged the landscape producers used a
garbage dump in mexico city as a
stand-in at san diego comic-con in 2012
damon spoke to the curious crowd and
told them about filming the sci-fi epic
and how the landfill location was mostly
fecal matter the helicopters would come
through and we'd be black with dust neil
would come over with his mask and said i
promise you the photography looks great
filming for the 2015 alejandro inari to
wilderness epic the revenant was
notoriously difficult the director
himself called the production's harsh
conditions a nightmare filmed on
location in the canadian rockies the
crew dealt with bitterly cold
temperatures that made production
difficult and inuritu was heavily
criticized for pushing his cast and crew
too hard under harsh conditions in a
shoot that went at least five months
over schedule some crew members
reportedly ranked it among the worst
experiences of their career one cast
member who didn't complain however was
lead leonardo dicaprio to get into
character and deliver his gut-wrenching
performance dicaprio known for going
above and beyond for his films went to
extreme lengths that included sleeping
in animal carcasses and eating raw bison
liver he shared in a 2015 interview
whether it's going in and out of frozen
rivers or sleeping in animal carcasses
or what i ate on set i was enduring
freezing cold and possible hypothermia
constantly i certainly don't eat raw
bison liver on a regular basis when you
see the movie you'll see my reaction to
it because alejandro kept it in it says
it all it was an instinctive reaction
for the effort inuritu would become just
the third director to win back-to-back
academy awards for best director while
dicaprio would take home his first best
actor trophy
based on the smash hit comic book by
todd mcfarlane 1997's spawn is
infamously remembered today for its over
the top sometimes silly tone but the
cast was certainly taking it seriously
john leguizamo's character for instance
appears as a nauseating bulbous street
punk in bizarre facial makeup whose
disgust for humans is rivaled only by an
appetite for all things horrifying in
one scene the character eats a pizza
covered with live maggots like some
other instances above this immediately
led to a debate among viewers about how
real the scene actually was eventually
the conversation got so loud that the
actor himself had to respond he tweeted
in 2014 yes i did eat maggots and spawn
but i only swallowed a few he followed
it up by warning his fans not to try it
at home he said
don't go there
shia labeouf has earned the reputation
of a hollywood eccentric and in the
right hands this can sometimes translate
to powerful on-screen work this was the
case when his talents were tested in
david ayer's acclaimed 2014 world war ii
picture fury along with much of the cast
labeouf took part in several weeks of
military boot camp alongside a group of
navy seals star brad pitt said it was
set up to break us down to keep us cold
to keep us exhausted to make us
miserable to keep us wet make us eat
cold food
but la buff who played a tank driver in
the film took his method performance
one step further going so far as to
having one of his teeth removed he
explained on jimmy kimmel live that it
wasn't as easy as one might think saying
it's not like you can go to some dentist
and go in there like hey i want to get
this tooth taken out they were like you
want to do what that doesn't make any
medical sense at all but ultimately
labeouf insists that he got it done
because he wanted to add some depth to
the character he added i found a guy in
resida next to a radio shack he didn't
ask too many questions to further method
this madness fury co-star logan lerman
told an interviewer that the scar on the
buff's cheek in the film was not only
real but self-inflicted lerman explained
they were putting cuts on shia and i
said yeah yeah it looks good and shia
was like no it doesn't look real so he
walks out into the hallway and says hey
man want to see something fun check this
out and he takes out a knife and cuts
his face for the whole movie he kept
opening these cuts on his face that's
all
real
among the most intensely dedicated
actors in hollywood today christian bale
always finds a way to stand out he
notoriously lost 60 pounds for the 2004
flick the machinist then immediately
bulked up to play batman for the werner
herzog vietnam war drama rescue don bale
combined these methods and more taking
on the role of real-life war hero and
u.s navy pilot dieter dengler bale
committed himself fully to embodying the
part of the long-suffering hostage of
the patetlau tortured and starved the
movie portrays dengler's struggle to
endure his captivity staying alive for
his ultimate rescue by american forces
bale once again put his heart and soul
into a part challenging himself both
physically and mentally during the shoot
these adversities included wrestling a
real snake losing more than 60 pounds
and being physically abused as part of
several torture scenes but perhaps the
most nauseating bale ate live maggots in
an attempt to portray the depths of
desperation his real-life character had
reached during imprisonment he said in a
2007 interview oh yeah those were real
maggots they were very real i didn't
mind eating the maggots asked what he
wouldn't do the actor remarked that
being set a blaze is something that
crosses the line look i've done other
things where people have to be set on
fire and jump through stories i'm not
doing that i've got limits what's the
difference between you and me
i'm not wearing hockey pads
veteran actor tony todd has had multiple
iconic supporting roles over the years
in movies like platoon and night of the
living dead but it's his part as the
titular horror villain in the 1992 film
candyman that has become his calling
card his booming voice terrified
moviegoers in multiple films and has
haunted dreams for nearly 30 years
you're mine now
but it was more than todd's imposing
deep voice towering physical presence
and razor sharp hook that scared viewers
the franchise has depicted swarms of
bees crawling out of him from his
sleeves his chest and even his mouth and
keep in mind that in the early 90s cgi
was a costly rarely utilized option for
horror films as a result swarms of real
bees were used on set and actor tony
todd endured it all receiving more than
20 bee stings during the shoot but
don't feel too bad for the thespian he
made a smart deal with the film's
producers that ended up putting some
good money in his pocket alongside all
that calamine lotion he told
entertainment weekly while looking back
on the film in 2019 i negotiated a bonus
of one thousand dollars for every sting
during the bee scene and i got stung 23
times everything that's worth making has
to involve some sort of pain once i
realized it was an important part of who
candyman was i embraced it it was like
putting on a beautiful coat
the 2012 movie the paperboy didn't make
many waves with critics or at the box
office but at the time of its release
the film was nonetheless discussed
albeit for all the wrong reasons set in
1969 paperboy tells the tale of a
reporter who goes back to his childhood
hometown to prove the innocence of a
death row inmate found guilty of
murdering the local sheriff matthew
mcconaughey plays the intrepid reporter
but a tawdry secondary story involves
the film's other two leads zac efron
placed his younger brother jack and
nicole kidman plays an out-of-towner
named charlotte hess girlfriend of the
accused one scene in the film has
ephron's jack ward getting badly injured
and stung by a group of jellyfish as pop
culture of the last few decades would
have you believe there's only one way to
overcome such pain and that's by having
someone give you an impromptu golden
shower according to the cleveland clinic
this is indeed just a myth so please
don't pee on friends and family without
first consulting a doctor for the scene
in question kidman actually urinated on
zac efron daniel said in a 2012
interview we just went for it and never
thought twice about it because it made
sense for the film it was what it was as
the flick made its way through
post-production daniels began getting
doubts but oscar winner kidman
encouraged him to stick by his instincts
daniels recalled i think that i became
more nervous about it in the edit room
and i thought i'm not actually going to
show this right is it vulgar and i
called nicole and said i don't know and
she said lee you made me pee on zac
efron if you don't put it in the movie
you need to man up and i was like
alright
joaquin phoenix is known for his
eccentric ways throwing himself into
films like joker and i'm still here for
paul thomas anderson's 2012 film that
flirted with the origins of scientology
and the struggle between faith and free
will however phoenix may have gone to
his most extreme portraying freddie
quell a veteran of the second world war
suffering from post-traumatic stress
disorder phoenix got very method so much
so that he even wired parts of his jaw
shut so he could achieve the character's
awkward speech patterns it's a move
somewhat reminiscent of how method hero
marlon brando used cotton balls to land
the role of don corleone but it also
made for a wholly unique performance in
the master one that landed phoenix an
oscar nomination phoenix explained the
story in 2014 saying my dad sometimes
would talk out of the side he'd clench
down one side of his mouth and i just
thought it represented tension in this
way somebody that's just blocked and
tight so i actually went to my dentist
and i had them fasten these metal
brackets to my teeth on the top and the
bottom and then wrapped rubber bands
around it to force my jaw shot on one
side phoenix went on to explain after a
couple weeks the bands they weren't
really strong enough to kind of hold it
so i ended up getting rid of the rubber
bands and i still had these metal
brackets in and so it made me constantly
aware of my cheek you know they had
these pointy tips so they'd tear up the
cheek a little bit
tim burton's batman returns had some
unsettling moments many of them
belonging to danny devito's penguin his
grotesque appearance and disgusting
eating habits made it a bit unpleasant
if you were attempting to chow down on a
tub of popcorn but it was the eating
habits of the other villain that makes
this list in particular an infamous
scene involving a little birdie during
the scene in question the villainous
catwoman puts a live bird in her mouth
as a way of threatening devito's penguin
actress michelle pfeiffer who had beat
out the likes of sean young and madonna
for the in-demand part was determined to
do more than simply toss a rubber prop
into her mouth and call it a day instead
the actress wanted the full effect
particularly the bird fleeing the coop
when she opened her mouth and actually
put a real live bird in her mouth for
the scene nice birdie
these days after special effects and cg
have spent decades rendering audiences
accustomed to cinematic trickery you
might not appreciate the lengths
pfeiffer went to for the scene unless
you know the backstory burton told the
hollywood reporter in 2017 i don't think
i've ever been so impressed she had a
live bird in her mouth while the camera
was rolling it was four or five seconds
and then she let it fly out it was
before cg it was before digital it was
so quick it seems like it was an effect
pfeiffer said of the scene i look back
and say
what was i thinking i could have gotten
a disease or something from having a
live bird in my mouth it seemed fine at
the time i don't think the bird was
drugged or anything we did that scene in
one take
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite movies are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one